large crowds and eu flags are plenty in
central warsaw and real fears for the
country's future
we would like to stay in the european
union and we are very afraid that
that we are going to
to the poll exit together with the
government of mr kaczynski and the
others here
it's like
you know a magician who is playing a
young magician who is playing with
fire and he doesn't know how to
how to stop so it can explode so i think
it's the same here
they don't really know what they do
since the constitutional tribunal ruled
on thursday that foundational parts of
eu law don't apply in poland opposition
politicians and eu supporters have been
mobilizing
the turnout here reinforces a central
point support for the european union in
poland is overwhelming some 75 to 80
percent of the population not even the
ruling law and justice party really
questions poland's membership of the
european union so it begs a question
why is the government picking such a
potentially dangerous fight with
brussels
we did invite poland's government and
supporters in the media to explain their
position but none took the opportunity
so i put the question to adam bodner
until being ousted by the same tribunal
that ruled against the eu he was
poland's human rights ombudsman
it seems to me that government would
simply like to accept okay we can take
the money we can take all those benefits
but please leave us alone when it comes
to any pressure concerning the
compliance with any
european
standards but it is impossible simply
because you cannot be at the same time
member of the european union and ignore
basic rules of european
integration
the eu is thinking about its response it
neither wants to let this slide nor
worsen the dispute
we will react of course like like we
have done in the the last weeks and
months you have seen that again we are
waiting now for new decisions of the
court of justice about the situation in
poland also possible
daily financial sanctions
the constitution now joins issues like
judicial reform abortion and lgbt rights
connected fronts in a power struggle
between poland's government and the eu
that's getting worse not better rory
challen's al jazeera warsaw